[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shaq
barrett joins us now you're my mvp shaq
is the party still going on in tampa
oh i don't think the party's going to
stop for a long time now
and i appreciate you having me on the
show as well well i thought the defense
was the star here
and i thought the defense was the reason
why you guys got to the super bowl in
the first place what you did in the
previous games there but
it's almost like we the media kept
forgetting about how good you guys were
uh did that bother you guys going into
the super bowl
oh no no it didn't bother us at all we
knew what we meant to the team we knew
the road we played and everything
as long as we got that super bowl ring i
mean [ __ ] [ __ ] say
whoever won the game it don't matter we
got the ring i don't care we know it was
a team effort we all
like stepped up in the biggest game of
our lives and made it happen
all right so what was the game plan
against mahomes
uh to be able to get pressure on them
with four man like we did against raj
and then to keep him in a pocket we know
he's good at uh improvising getting out
the pocket making them plays making them
grows and he still was able to do it
some in our game but
we we uh limited as much as possible and
we was able to close out on them and not
give them time to make them throws like
once he rolled down and scrambled up
well also he's got that bad toe and i
don't know if that factored in as well
that he they they i guess looked at it
and said he rushed
he ran for over 400 yards trying to
scramble
the uh the entire evening did did he
seem like he was
not the same patrick mahomes mobility
wise
no no no he still uh he still looked
good to me i mean
only he knew how he really felt but i
know he put everything he
played to the best of his capabilities
with that toe injury
because i know he ain't going to have
anything limited in them but he looked
normal he was
mobile escaping like yeah he looked
normal
did he say anything to you during the
game
no i didn't think i uh got a chance to
talk i was too busy talking to the other
guys on
the team but yeah i i say anything tom
ain't saying nothing to me oh wait who
you talking to on the chiefs the lineman
yeah yeah i was talking to the line and
then occasionally when the defense was
crossed
i was talking to a couple of the
defensive guys too what'd you say to the
lineman
hey they just uh they just got me going
they got me going i told them like uh
just once they started talking it was
admitted a longer day for them
but uh it was majority 77-75 rumors
wasn't talking too much but 77 was
talking a lot and i
wanted to make him eat his words for
sure yeah i thought remembers
uh you know he didn't do well against
von miller a few years ago in the super
bowl and i thought
boy he's going to go up against you i i
was surprised they didn't make
adjustments shaq
like were you guys surprised they didn't
make adjustments at halftime
yeah yeah i was uh pretty surprised i
don't think the chips started coming
like consistent chip blocks
was until like late third quarter or
fourth quarter that's when
like i still i'm rushing rushing getting
off the edge
beating the tackles but then a running
back will tighten it'll be right there
and it just messed up the whole rush but
like yeah i saw the adjustments lately
in the game but at that point it was
already past the two lead spot
take me back to the first time you met
brady
the first time i met you so it was a in
the locker room i saw him in the locker
room just went up tom
said what's up glad to have you here
like that's the first time we met in
person and he was uh
he was all loved too man it was just a
great uh feeling like we respect each
other games
we know what we brought to the game and
we uh we're just happy to be able to get
it going together but the first time i
talked to him was on instagram
just saying the same thing happy to have
you here like just wanting to bring some
of this winning ways down the table and
that's exactly what he did
we was all ready to just gravitate to
him and learn none of them did you get
to get on his boat have you been on his
boat
no i have not been on his boat i didn't
i did not make it to his boat
did you see him yesterday i saw him
yesterday a little bit i saw a video
but i was like shaq shaq he looked like
he had been sacked he was in concussion
protocol when he came off that boat
hey that's how i should be man this was
a great affair especially
for him having success outside of new
england i know that's probably what he
wanted to prove
to everybody even though he knew he
could do it but uh just to
get rid of that debate was it just
because of new england or was it
both of them together and like he uh he
most definitely
ended that debate for show what do you
think my new nickname uh
tb 12-pack
uh was gronk uh what we've
come to expect with gronk or was he a
little more subdued in the uh
celebration
uh from what i saw it was it was grunt
of old
like having fun partying like i saw
videos before after they won the super
bowl
and it was uh the same grunt for me man
he he's always like he's the same
even without one of the super bowl in
the locker room he's always a lot of
energy
fun to be around he's just uh he's a
good guy to be around man
how do you keep this team together shaq
that's a great question but uh
mr light up top ba they are hey they
did a good job of getting this together
i know they got to go have a good plan
to keep us together man because it's a
great organization
seem like they making all the right
moves from
the last two years that i've been a part
of it i'm happy to be a part of it and i
know that uh
if there's a will is a way and it is a
will so we're gonna figure out the way
to get it done
okay but you got a contract coming up
yeah yeah yeah i uh i almost definitely
like
tab i want to be in that time but and i
figured i feel they feel the same way so
we're going to find a way to get it done
for sure
i think you're going to do well though
jack i think you're going to do well
i'm looking forward to it man it's a
great position to be in and it's crazy
after last year
who would have thought that the position
could become even better and becoming a
better position for me to be in
and that's where i'm at right now and
i'm just standing in the moment
trying to take advantage of it and just
still focusing to even get better next
year because i think i played well but i
didn't play the way i wanted to play all
year
this past season so i'm uh working on
that but take me back to november
you guys had lost three in a row you're
seven and five and
any doubts start to creep in whether
it's privately
oh no i don't think no doubt ever uh
started creeping and we just knew uh
like guys on the team we all been in
situations similar to that before
like where we've been a good team and
then we go on a little slide like that
but it's up to the leaders of the team
coaches game plan everything to get
everybody going back and standing in the
right direction and that's what we was
able to do was able to bounce back
put together uh so what we went away we
haven't lost since then huh
since seven to five we haven't lost and
i don't think so
yeah so we we found a way to go on a
writing that's what b.a says
uh get hot at the right time and like
you'll be exactly where you want to be
at the end of the year that's what we
did
just stayed in there stayed mentally
focused and trying to become more
mentally focused
just executing a game plan and that's
how we ended up
whatever what we was that one in the
super bowl what did you keep from the
super bowl
uh the only thing i really care about
the most is the jersey man i got the
guys that signed the jersey
i'm looking forward to uh hanging that
up but i got the super bowl shirt super
bowl hat
i still got the little tags the
credentials that we got to wear in the
super bowl
i got shoe the mess i got everything
man i got everything uh
well hey you're our mvp and uh
congratulations that was a wonderful
season but certainly a wonderful game
turned in by
you guys and todd bowles deserves a lot
of credit too because
whatever happened that first meeting
wasn't going to happen in that second
meeting
uh as far as with kansas city right yep
yep he did a great job man the game plan
always been
good with coach bowles it was good the
first time we was in position but we
just didn't make the plays
and uh like that's what you could see
the biggest difference was we was in
position again the last time when we
made the plays
but uh coach bowles a heck of a
coordinator man a heck of a coordinator
i'm it's very sweet that he didn't get a
head coaching job because
i want him to have the success he wants
and i want him to have a job that he
wants
but i'm happy that he coming back to us
as a coordinator again and he did real
good for us
hey congratulations uh job well done we
appreciate your time and good luck with
uh your new contract shaq i appreciate
it thanks for having me on
that's a great time and a great year
that's shaq
barrett reason to smile there got to
keep him